[Music]
[Applause]
or the company against the clock I'm starting
and
my name is Enrique López I'm sure to
program
Google's professional services center and well
today I'm going to be the opening act for what I
think is really important and that is  the
presentation that is going to be made to us on
Friday from the national center for
renewable energies regarding their
experience with google cloud because it is
the selection of google cloud and what use they
have made of it and what future use they are going to
make of the platform so  they stop 30
minutes with me from xavier's talks
let's say that I have a lot to
tell you and a little time is worth
the first thing a little is to know and also
introduce what the motivation of the
session is so if there are people still in
so much but if you can tell me  what
experience do you have with google cloud if
you have any experience with google
cloud platform or not just raise your
hand so I can get an idea there are
quite a few people with experience in google
cloud platform
At my profile level, I'm a developer.
I'm more of a system person. I'm more of a
system architecture person.
Okay, developers.
Okay, perfect. Well, really, the
purpose of the talk is to give you an
introduction to the
different services where we can
execute code within the Google Cloud.
introductory talk we have to
cover in this case four services in
half an hour with which you will understand and
those of you who have experience with
google cloud platform are not going to
discover anything new perhaps or yes or
maybe if you do not have experience in
each and every one of  the services but the idea
is to describe to you what capabilities
these services have and then give you some
brushstrokes some ideas of how
your workloads can fit well
in each of these services are ideas
are brushstrokes each case of each client
is completely different there we go
to always have time for questions and
answers but free senses later
ment to deal with each case
in more detail and be able to fine-tune things a little
more and finally we will go on
to Xavier's talk which I think is
extremely interesting
because we are going directly to the point we are going to
start with the first of them as
you can see we are going to go in  order of what
the stack would be the stack first we start with
infrastructure as a service what they are
virtual machines pure computation
something that you are normally using in
your organization with the advantages and
capabilities that the cloud has and in
particular google chrome term that
we will go  going up to the
container
part to the platform as a service part and
finally functions as a service ok
then compute who is our
service of virtual machines of
infrastructure as a service
basically some of the capacities
that computer has and
differential creation of the offer that there
is outside is  that it is relatively easy to get up and
running with computing provisioning
machines  a very fast way these
machines are provisioned very soon
you can create machines based on
templates that we have predefined to be
able to create our own templates
your own images within google
as it was postponed you cannot import machines
from your data center through a
machine import service that
we have inside  of the
google cloud platform basically you put
people you can replicate it even use it
for disaster recovery situations
or migrations to google cloud
virtual machines are paid per minute
they are not paid per hour if you set up a
virtual machine for 15 minutes I pay 15
minutes and nothing more  this means that for
certain types of environments it has many
advantages for auto-
scaling issues, for example paying only for the
minutes in which I have that demand and
again for the entire hour for clusters
, israel was not counted in the
plenary session the frets of  'use and throw away'
paying by the minute you can use it for half an
hour and throw away  the cluster and pay only
because for that half hour, in addition to
paying per minute, we have certain
capabilities in terms of
discounts for use, the more you
use the machine, the more discount is
applied automatically without you
having to do much, we have
commitment if you commit to running a
certain amount of cpu and
memory machines with us you have
additional discounts etcetera etcetera etcetera
the machines can be very powerful and
this is already out of date this what
the cloud has to do is one is
half a week ago and  the following week things have
already changed we can run
machines with more memory than what it says
and of the 416 we can reach 455 gigabytes
of memory we can have gpu and
soon we will be able to have 3 which is our
processor that we have created for everything
that  it has to do with match in
learning in particular with tensor flow and
something also very interesting and that has
to do with the economic issue is the
yes  ghtseeing machines our matrix
of families is relatively simple
in balanced machines machines with more
compute than memory machines with more
memory than compute and then you have the
option without any of those in boxes to
choose the size of machine you
want ok you can select the number
of processors and the memory that is
best coupled to your workload and
all of this if you sustained on that
networking that they have been
telling you about, it speaks to us about the network that
connects all the regions and all the
data centers of google, but the very
networking that  you can put it to work
within google cloud where you have
your own network environment your
ubpc you can define your supra of
our
load balance firewall routing rules
etc. on which
computen gym is sustained something important about computing
engine are the disks
we basically have two types  of disks
a type of disk that is like a
service are persistent disks and
if you want to see it, disk is given from
machines that are not where
your computation is, they are separated, they are
consumed through a service, they are
persistent, and there we have the
possibility of hdd disks or sd disks,
the disk is decoupled from the machine,
I can change it and give it to  another
machine at some point and make
snapshots that can be full first and
then completely incremental and you
can do hot disk racing,
well, I also have the
possibility of having disks in read mode
shared by several
virtual machines and the size of those disks
has  impact on the group that they can
give to the virtual machines as well as the
size of the virtual machine in the case of
things that in the cloud to make an
incorrect size you have to take into account what
capacity the virtual machine has
because that at the memory computation level
Well, it affects the network issue as it can
process the packets and therefore the
access to the disk and the size of the disk as well.
Let's go to disk football and then
we have local disks in the machines
of two types that are basically disks
that are ephemeral they don't live no if the
machine pays for it what you have on the
disk you lose it but they have
brutal performance capabilities okay
but what  What I was commenting on are not just
virtual machines, but also the series of
services around the
virtual machines, I can have what we
call manage instance groups, which is
basically based on a template and
based on policies, being able to create
auto-scaling policies not based on
average consumption of cpu of the farm or based on the
latency of a balance I get
balancing services I have the possibility of
doing auto healing be a
manage install group
machine I get that machine automatically it balances the
machines I have in the
different data centers  of the different
availability zones in the regions
in which working coupled with cdn is
now not only the computation  per se but
everything else that surrounds google cloud
platform fits into all this is
a virtual machine where you are
the ones who manage the machine and
you can mount everything you want on top of it
then everything fits in basically everything
you are doing in your
datacenters fits in  within google
chrome maybe the only thing is some little things
to have clusters with
shared read/write disk because
we don't have that kind of thing
in google cloud but good gpu licensing issues is
no longer a matter of
services but of what you want to mount
that the  provider in terms of access to
it limitations because limitations are
those that you often have in your
own data center and that is that you
are completely in charge of the stack with
which you do not move up in it is here
you can perhaps eliminate tasks that do not
provide any benefit  to the
organization and dedicate them to something more
valuable but you have to continue
doing the maintenance of all  or this is
okay I make a small demo from the switch
so you can see this quickly
this is the google cloud console in
this case the first thing I wanted to show you
something interesting is for example
I have a provisional
virtual machine and one of the things they
provide  commented services are
recommendations of saiz and so that the
rays money in this case if you see
directly here it is warning me
that I have a machine that is
oversized I could directly
see the warning and it tells me hey if you change
this machine to another type you will
saving a lot of money I
could even do the racing directly from
the machine and pass it to that smaller
instance and save money throughout
this month ok
I'm going to create a machine with which I could
import it from one that has my own
talent in another provider  cloud when creating
an instance
because
I have to choose where I want to run
that instance in the multiple data
centers that google cloud c has  As it was
said israel yesterday we opened and webs webs 2
which is the london region when
we have two regions in europe in
this case I am going to run in the region because
one sees I can choose between the different
families that I have the type of machine
but I can choose
the number of virtual cpu's and memory that
I want to measure for example I am going to
choose 4 and from here I am going to choose 13
for example one of the things that
computen jim is going to tell me is hey if you choose 13
you know that for the same  price that
you can buy a larger pre-
configured instance what we don't want you to
spend money on in an inappropriate way
we will tell you directly even
if it says here 14 it will tell me hey
you can save dollars per month if
you take an instance a little bit a
little bit  bigger good as it pays google
and I'm going to choose it okay as for the
disk catalog of images
custom images that I may have created in
this case for example an apache has
created a machine put a  apache and I
have it already given here as an image that
I can continue provisioning and
interesting things like I said from here to
configure the http https access to this
machine and
advanced networking issues and how to
choose the subnets if I had
a network topology from which  I am not going to
get more sophisticated below
to deploy all of this, then
there are also script automation things,
well there is a whole world between
lightning but basically I can create my
machine that will be working shortly
and in this case how I have it
configured  this is not usually once
practice it is only for demo mode I will be able to
directly access this machine via ssh
directly from the console it
is working on it so as not to waste time
because we are running very short of time
directly I am going to access, for example,
another machine from my own  console
I can access wiese sh and start
managing the machine as if I were the
administrator of it I can do
what and  or consider
necessary is a little bit the very brief idea
of what some of the capabilities you have
ith computing we return to the slide
to devel
p is the perfect excel but there are n
t many more computing engin
sessions perhaps the dot net for what's in go
gle cloud platform etc.  but
in general what we are going to talk about at the
highest level in the extractor if you have
doubts
you can see me here and talk about whatever you
want there are also the sessions of the
next 'san francisco' there were many
more sessions around computer
container engine here  we rise
in it is here we talk about containers
who uses containers today
is not bad and who plans to use them
well I understand that all of you
try the advantages and benefits that
containers have and that in my
opinion is one of the things  that
the approach to service delivery is going to change a lot
within both the
datacenters that you have in your
organizations and at the club level  For
some benefits, it is to abstract
myself from the infrastructure provider that I have
below, so that is why the container
allows me to package an application with
all the components, make it
self-contained in such a way that I
can take it, I end the container, to
any site, to any
infrastructure, operating system that
supports the  running
repeatability containers everything that has to do
with software deployments looks very
much improved et cetera et cetera and then there
's how do I do this at scale how do I take
the containers and know what resources they need where do you put them how do you
analyze them analyzed how in case of  fall I
mount more containers as I expose them
to the outside and that is what it is q vernet
is okay rulers is a layer of
automation
the name in Greek is the helmsman the one who
governs everything everything that are the
containers that go below and with
these  two container objects and
rulers allows me to abstract in
infrastructure that there is p  or below in
such a way that I can modernize my
concurrent application with the
governor objects and make it work on
google cloud platform in another
cloud provider or directly in my own
data center ok and here we raise the
level while what you said
above the data  plane as if
we were saying it is the iron with the hypervisor
and control place the console and high
virtual machines at this level what
we are talking about is the cuber net cluster it is
like data plane and the control plane is the
console or in the command line  of
governor where it started provisioning
services to applications it really is worth
what it is to contain in ying because it is a
governor it is managed it is a service
q see before managed where
I can quickly put a cluster of q
vernet to work is that
[Music]
the provision of the 'cluster'  covers test
can be done declaratively with
a file a file called the
provisional tetrapod 'cluster' of cuber net is
flexible  interpol alex cooper net is
then it is interoperable with any
other similar environment it can take something
they have q bernese seed data
center import it to container engine without
any work the basic idea is to
remove the work of provisioning
clusters from cuber net is that it does not contribute
anything and  dedicating myself to parameterizing or
managing cooper net itself is
also supported there kers the content
that runs below is based on touches
of various containerization formats and we
also provide
container images ourselves and all
are based again on the same networking and
security  that google cloud platform
provides the rest of the services in the
good fit whoever is looking at
hybrid environments whoever is in the world
of content delivery continues
integration
etc. code pipelines whoever is
looking at microservices this type of
technology fits very well with the
philosophy with which  infrastructure as
code I define it
declaratively within the
cubanet deployment descriptors is if I can
repeat and create environments and create the
entire code pipeline
the limitations, well, those of
the container itself is that not everything is still
largely yes, but in other content I
talked about what there is  to have knowledge
for all this, sometimes the
state persistence issues because it requires
working on them and above all, especially the
part of people and processes because you have
to start managing services and that you
start managing 'clusters' of
governors
in all of your  sense and many times we are not
prepared our processes and
our people to do it
let me show you a little demo
we return to the demo
ok
here what I have is a whole
sercla blanch you are like the marketplace where
I have different possibilities of
provisioning both predesigned virtual machines
with  some software in
question is worth in the case we have
images of containers  that are generated
and maintained by google we take
care of modifying and
maintaining this type of images in
this case for example I have the engine
gce at a given moment where I can see
the information and where the image in
question is
now I go to the  part of it because the
first part is the containers and not the
rest that they need doesn't go
anywhere so I'm going to the
containers part sorry google that
contains tenchini I'm going to create a cluster
then
we're going to give it the pretty name of  demo
again the same thing I have to choose the
region where I want to run the cluster in
question the machines that are going to
support it or it sounds a bit like what we have
seen previously not for example
the machines that are going to support the
cluster the operating system of the  cluster
which in this case is with if it is cloud
optimize content that more operating
system is our operating system
optimized to run in containers and
then some pair  If you
want us to take care of the
upgrades of the hub net level from
the clusters, if you want us to take
care of the self-repair of the
new ones in the cluster in case
any of them go down, and if you want good
backwards compatibility issues with
certain models of access to the clusters
also if you have a network
below where you want to place the cluster
in question and there are some more things that, well,
provisional here but I will not
go into detail only one see
video of how easy it is to launch a priori
a cuban cluster before with this
I already have a cluster recover 40 is launched
we would be in this at this level where
the base has already been created which will begin to
deploy my applications so what
I have to go to is the
cuber net console it is already  I'm forgetting about
infrastructure here we're not going to
talk about machines or anything like that anymore,
but about being
what I'm going to do is at the level of q
vernet is that it's a level of abst  ration
superior to that of machines take off
one well for example the engine that we have
seen previously
we are going to call it
the image I have here
this is the image of
in links
ok I want
here there are some additional parameters
for example if I want to know how many
resources this container requires to
that I governed test I can place it in
one of the nodes of the cluster where
there are available resources
and I am going to deploy it directly ok
it is already being deployed in hits as
you can see it is very simple provisioned the
cluster and in this case I can already deploy
in links by  above
[Music]
which is already deployed and one of
the things that I can do for example is
directly on top of it for example how
easy it is to auto-scale because the
contents are very light so this
all this is usually done per line of
command those who know a lot about all this
with the qb ctl etc. I do not
confuse people directly here in the
information  tion of the deployment itself because
I
can see that this was too small
for me it was
here for example instead of one in jeans
we are going to move to 10 innings
I am going to deploy 10 containers in
parallel that above here there is no
load balancer
and as you can see
well little by little the containers are being created
up to 10 and
I can make all of them accessible from the outside
I have services that expose these in
jeans
from the outside and I can access this
soloist and it is not the previous cake
sorry
for example this
is to say very quickly here  not as
you can see I have not talked at any time about
machines but about taking a container I have
said certain requirements here vernet
is it has been deployed to me in the new
recurring cluster that it has provisioned
- exposes it out and I can do is
that the audi skill down also  Just like when I
put a 10, I can put a 1 again and
the number of innings that I already had is
reduced to 1 again very quickly and
very agilely, it's worth it  n which in certain
scenarios where auto
scaling etc. is required and the ease of
provision is much higher, the
level is higher and if we go back to the light classes
more information talks you have a very
good one the next one if you want to learn
real recoverers stay in the
next session  ok appengine
we raise the bar again here we talk about
platform as a service here
basically someone develops strip
code based on the forums that are
supported by the app engine
configures some information
of the app engine service a little bit and
automatically executes a
command line and  deploys the application does not
have any select and there is no
machine concept does not exist around here just
upload the application app engine what you
get for using the service is that
all that is auto scaling
balancing the application making the
application  run in all the data
centers is that it has the
selected region of google that we can
do s  traffic plit we can do it
and be testing etc. etc. I have it
by default all that is simply for
using the platform obviously I have
restrictions restrictions that have
been alleviated with the exit of the app engine
flexible' where we allow ourselves to put
certain things inside the
machines so that it can
execute code that it previously had,
which is very restricted to frying and
libraries that supported appengine
fits everything that is web applications
I have seen the case of the baby has commented
is app engine with which all that
are web applications that require  a
vitesse teen spirit' traffic auto
scaling and I don't have to worry about
all the rules and if not
the service does it immediately or whatever they are
to vis
within the app engine we have the concept
of versioning service with which
everything that  be they apis or even
microservices developed on the app
engine the invitations fit very well
is that in the standard version I am
l  imitated by the run times that are
supported and I have little ability to
modify this, this is alleviated with the
flexible app engine' okay, it allows me to
get my hands on it, but in this get my hands on it is to
put containers with which the
limitation that the ones it had also may have
with containers we are going to see a
very quick demo
of the app engine so you are left with the sole
idea
the first thing is worth when you start with the app
engine it is good to select the language
in which you want to program and the region
in which you want to deploy your
application I will choose  europe because
of being close ok and that's it with this
I already have app engine provisioned in my
region of Europe then what I
have to do is as a developer to
have my code
what I really have here is a
very simple application with a little
code  in python
ok
what i am going to do is this is the
descriptor i am going to pass to beijing so
that it configures the application and the only
thing i have to do
is caf  he
is working on it and then what should
appear here if everything goes well
is that you create a new service
ok here you have the new service in
this case or next it only has one version
I am going to modify
a little bit in the application code
nonsense  but I'm going to put version 2
and I'm going to try to upload it it's still working
on it by the way I haven't commented on this
what's here is klaus the klaus he
's a shell in the cloud that I can
connect to and I have a little
little code editor  text editor
ok it's taking a bit longer
than I like and we don't have much time
so plan plan b ok in this case
I can see the service that was
running either directly
coded and launched my command line
and automatically I have the service
provisioned in the cloud and one of the
things that I can do with all this is,
for example, to divide the traffic. In
this case, I have two versions
working and I can have policies that
make me split.  of the traffic
automatically to do the ibi
testing etcetera etcetera
good for you to have an idea
of what the app engine is with which we ar
going to raise the bar as you see here so th
re is nothing about machines in which verne
is we are still going to deploy  a
cluster and it asked me for cpu memory here it
directly coded and launched the
platform as a service we put the
slides
there are more sessions also from ave nor from
jorge it is spectacular that I
also invite you to meet or if you wanted to delve
into the part of beijing that  I think it's
at three, no, that's
the last level of transfusions, cloud
functions, and those functions as a service, it
's a certain code that I want to be
executed basically based on an event
that is generated, you
don't have to worry about the machines where
that code is executed or the  auto
scaling when I have a lot of demand for
many events of that code, that is taken
care of by the service, I only have to
take care of putting the code and saying
what events it responds to  is going to generate that code and
we take care of everything else, that's
okay, then where does it fit well because the
topic ended up serving them and server
can be in integration, for example, it is
used a lot in integration mechanisms
between services in the cloud, that is to say,
something happens that  generates an event that
emits a function that takes whatever it is
and leaves it in cloud storage that generates an
event that executes a function that does
something with it that this has arrived now
this type of glue puts it not
only for google cloud services  But
for any type of glue of something
that is running in the cloud, it is one of
the first uses that is given to this type
of environment and a little later,
because back-end as a service or
API functions can put pieces
behind an API.  gateway such
as pizzi is ours and directly
put the code there to work and be
invoked
when someone wants to use it the
limitations that every function has
basically is  that today there is only
one train that also supports the
execution times and you cannot take
any code that is
running for three hours and put it in cloud
functions there are some limits in
what is the execution that are not bad
but it is something to  keep in mind and that it
only interacts via events events are
not only necessarily
google cloud events they can also be
http events any mechanism
anything that generates http can generate
events for confusion but it is only
via bentos there is no other
paradigm  interaction with the
service and they are sterile that must also
be taken into account when
executing codes okay and another small
very quick demo
so that you can get the idea
we are there because basically here what I
am going to create is a function
where the  I am going to execute the memory
that I am going to allocate to the execution of the
function in particular before which events
the function is going to be executed in this case it
is a  Before uploading something to a
cloud storage package, ok,
what is the code that I am going to execute,
so I have here
in this code, it
is nonsense, ok, Pérez, why
write with the tail, idea
and, well, a bouquet of styling, this
configuration topic  and what function is it that
I am going to expose from the code that
I have here band
and that's it, there is no more mystery now
when something uploads to that package
it will automatically execute a
code that what it will do is print
in the function cloud blog  it's not going to
do much it's not going to do great
wonders so what I'm going to do
now is upload an image and what better
image to upload these days to the cloud than
called vicente calderón so it suits
us
so we're going to upload the image
minutes
now to  wait for this function what it
executes is the print directly on the
blog
as we go time has already passed me
so with this believe me that we no longer go to
the presentation with this prints it makes it
good the idea is that you see  In the event of an event
, the slides are executed without problems, it
does not go,
the clicker does not work,
if you make me lights,
the time,
if they move or
not,
well, it summarizes the slides and while
we fix it, to give you time to know
what is really important, the
next  it's what's coming basically it's
not just
a technology issue it's important to
get where you want to go hey I'm
interested in cloud functions well put that
level if you want to get out of
traditional computing make the effort to
do it okay we set the level and then
see if it fits technologically  if there are
limitations that allow me to not
allow me to execute all this
and well this is here we do not
put a level of abstraction that
fits with what you want to achieve as a
company and work on it training
people the processes changing them has
many benefits but as  he said mba also
requires an effort that
obviously fits with the
technical requirements the limitations that I have
mentioned before  nte but above all
above all to put that level and at the level of
the organization team work to
achieve it
with which I pass quickly
I hope you have left a little
idea of how this service where it fits and r
view what I think it reall
is  interesting and it is up to xavier to have
the national center for renewable energies
to explain his experience with
google cloud and its evolution and its future is
worth a lot thank you
good morning because we will make the
most of the time you give us today xavier
nicuesa from the national center for renewable
energies  is a research center
in the field of renewable energies and
therefore we are dedicated to the generation of
knowledge in the field of
renewable energies to later generate others to
transmit it to the industry of the sector and
with that we intend to promote the
development of sustainable energy
activities to which we dedicate ourselves
to research applied to the
transfer of knowledge and  a
series of services such as evaluation,
homologation, accreditation and
certification and we do it in six areas
in biomass in the integration into the grid
of renewable energy wind solar
thermal solar photovoltaic and building energy
as part of the computing and
software development service we develop
many software but  today we bring two
concrete examples of how we have
moved from our in house to the
google cloud briefly they are examples
based on the codes one is the
scale table the scale table is within the
atmosphere some specific distances
in which the phenomena are resolved or analyzed
Atmospheric we are
very interested in the direction of the wind
with the sea breeze storms too and
so you know well there are a series
of models there are wolves girón here land and
the weather forecasts are also
based on these models that are
called mesoscale models because they
solve  At this average scale,
atmospheric phenomena  spherical
the cfd of the acronym in English
computational fluid dynamics what it
does is solve the
numerical equations of the fluids of the
hydrodynamics of the fluids widely
used in wind energy in
several others but in our
specific case in wind energy from
the design of the word wind turbine to the
analysis of what wakes are called
in the parks how the
positioning of a specific wind turbine
within a park affects those that
are subsequently located or how
the wind flow is analyzed in
different terrains for evaluation
of the good resource
as a technological center we have a
computing cluster on which we
have based ourselves until quite recently
in time it is a bio woolf cluster
that is to say it is a heterogeneous castell with the
characteristics of being a software a
low cost hardware sorry it is
based on  linux operating systems and
computing is in parallel using the
largest pos number  ible nodes
based on implementations of the
mp libraries
because we are a technology center we have
access to and participate in a large number
of research projects both at a
national and European level and that
gives us access to large
computing infrastructure centers at a
national level  well, perhaps the best known
are the sc, the mark johnston of the psc or the
cesga, however we are going to see that
within our mission of
technology transfer we are going to have a problem
with these large centers they are
public centers all in public financing
with which any project  that it be
developed using its infrastructure, it
has to make the results available to the entire
scientific community and the
industry, well, sometimes in this
sense it is a bit reticent, okay
then, what is our situation, well,
we have a cluster where our
executions are multi, not two, that is  say
we solve very large domains
need a lot of computing resource  tional
we manage everything through a
work queue manager our
specific case is ht condor and well
we are in a situation years ago
when the deployment of
virtualization began virtual machines well
try to follow the literature but
within the computing of  hpc is
a problem because if
we superimpose our code on a
virtual machine we are losing the performance
of the machine and of course what we
have are many users using
the cluster the computational resources
are all in the queue and what
they do not want is  that because you
facilitate scalability, they have
to waste time or delay the
results of their executions,
well, here we have a
problem that I have mentioned a little before,
which is the transfer of technology
that we intend to transfer what
we develop the analyzes and
codes  that develop to the
industry we can not use the
big ce  computational centers of the
scientific community but our
service is also beginning to be seen with
scalability deployment limitations and
then there is a change in
strategy as I say
[Music]
thanks also to the progress that is made
in the development of the processors
in which they are incorporating  several cores and
then a very specific case is in the
analysis of the wind resource we
do an analysis of the wind in the
entire circumference of the wind rose
that is 360 degrees and someone an
engineer from the sector of
the ico department comments well and yes  instead of
using the entire domain, the partition we have
in bing is 10 degrees, it turns out that
we no longer have a huge domain in which we
need a multi-mode configuration,
but we can solve it by
taking advantage of that capacity of
many colors in a single machine 8 or
10  32 64 colors and then
and that's where the new situation arises
we don't need to use in the
configuration  ion multi mode where for
us to use and not have
infinity because it is going to be a
bottleneck in all those communications and
we say well because we are going to try
clearly it turns out that a
multinational is approaching us in a
call for
research projects to  regional level in
Navarre and he tells us that we are
interested in what he proposes to us is
to execute it in the cloud, so let's get to
work and begin to test which is the
platform that may interest us the most,
the project has a time limit, we
cannot test all of them and we decide  that by
literature both amazon and google
cloud because they are the best positioned in
the market we tested amazon
perfectly the implementation is simple
where we can
execute them without any problem
we tried google cloud and again it
turns out that you have absolutely all
the steps in the documentation is
accessible via  online and right away
we got to have our
implementations running  or in the cloud
comes the moment of comparison,
both have been very simple to
implement but and this is true I am not going
to charge for it because in the
google results it was cheaper in price and we
obtained improvements in performance in
good times, well from there  we started the master's degree in
technology what enrique told us about
the backs is the
persistent disks the instances the images
you do the master's degree in rising which is good
because it costs but then it is a
tool that helps you a lot when it
comes to convincing and being able to develop
the  projects and one fine day, well, you
find that 36 are the management assets, it
is that we have to
solve the domain with machines with 32
cores, since we are launching the cases in
1,153 cores in parallel, something that was
impossible for us due to the
limitation of  physical scalability and
here not only a small note that when you
use the 3,300 6 that happens well
someone from google calls the phone that
you have done something  as a contact in the
quota increase request form
and the two of you who are and well, but
fortunately, with that begins a
relationship in which I, for my part,
can only thank all the
Google staff and their
tips engineers who  they have given us and well, you
help when it comes to how to solve,
especially with regard to architecture, how to
propose your solutions
what he was out there before
I told you that virtual machines
did not solve anything for us because
scalability was not  our problem
but if diego booker revealed and in terms of
reliability and in order to be able to deploy
internally even our software
was kind of interesting how you were
reading the topic of google cloud you get to
see metes you get to alge falls and it turns out
that someone says well then
stop stop  in
site evaluation we use domains that
are enormous, many kilometers long, and
we also have this problem of
multimode computing.  If it
occurs to you, we are going to make this domain
be resolved in the same way as the
previous case, taking advantage of the fact that each one of
the nodes can have up to 64 cores, and
well, that is how we set ourselves up and
develop a solution. In this case, it
is the cloud, those call modeling systems.
where it is a multinational company that is
also very strong in the wind sector, it
is very interested and arrives and tells you,
well, I have 500 sites,
I want it to run a model four
times a day and this for 365
days for the machines
- there are 16 CPUs and you go  to the calculator country
that you had before you put numbers and now
this when you call google and say this
will be a joke
it is not a joke in price because you
are saving you are talking about costs of
borders talking about it you are saving
in all the investment in necessary hardware
but without  However, as I have commented
to them, they help you in the
sense that they comment and you have seen,
I do not remember the name of the committee of
six that can  s to use where you
find discounts of up to 57%
on that price that they are giving you and
then how you are using the jack it is necessary to set
up a cluster where you can set
up different pools of different
types of machine and instead of using
all the regular instances
you can  use I turned on bless, which are
these machines that are going to pay you in 24 hours,
but hey, it's a matter of
strategy, you analyze your case, you can
raise pools of all the machines you
want, but preventable, and it turns out
that at that price I had seen and
I didn't have the guts to give it to the client
because in the end it's reducing
the value that you were going to give it by up to 6 percent
now that we find ourselves because there are
hyper problems I gave in to us
within high-performance computing it
's a problem because the
fictitious colors  in the end, what they
are doing to us is
delaying the executions a lot,
but sometimes we talk about 50 percent
, we are solving it  do well with the
free properties to
lmp implementation leagues and where are they going to allow us to
tell it to
somehow go beyond the fictitious colors and
only use the real ones we are
using 16 machines leave 16 but
telling it to use only 8 cores which are the
that I know it really has and we are
reducing the executions by more than 30%,
that is, we use the same
machine that we are saying to use
less copper but we achieve it in less
time
and well later by using the services
because in our executions it is
something very important in management
is typically something that is usually
solved with network-type databases
where you generate your job queue
where they are passed to the instances that are
deployed in the cluster and we
are passing that right now using
services such as data  about why
because anything that is
based on services without instances is
always going to have much more
availability and  Reliability is
always going to pick you up, cubanet will
always pick you up
when it comes to instance, because it can make
sure that the problem doesn't exist, it can't be
solved, and some of us are very
interested, because, as you mentioned,
management also enriches
communication and those glues
which is talked about when the
instances communicate and understand each other
because they are interested in seeing the parts of
puig and functions
and well and still studying it the truth
is that we have been with this for a year and a half
but very fascinated with the idea and getting
excited  so that you also do it at
least try it and I am a phenomenon
because I have fulfilled my time henríquez
thank you
now save your neck I thank you for 22
seconds well then just to thank how
much you have been with us so far we
invite you to stay in the
following  sessions that I think one of the
cuber net is very very interesting and that
you are having fun and that it serves to
do is worth a lot thanks to all
s alright thanks
[Music]